dans le reste de l'actualité aujourd'hui
les bons chiffres du chômage du mois de
septembre nous vous en parlions déjà
dans notre édition d'hier soir - 2,2 %
de demandeurs d'emploi dans les Yvelines
par rapport au mois d'août et c'est vos
chiffres profitent surtout au 25 49 ans
Haussmann vendeur de notre experts
économie nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
alors Osman est-ce que on peut enfin
parler de cette fameuse inversion de la
courbe du chômage et bien en tout cas
pour le président de la République c'est
ce sont des chiffres providentiels au 9e
mois de l'année le nombre d'inscrits à
Pôle emploi à diminué de
66300 personnes en France soit recul de
1,9% au niveau national et les Yvelines
tirent leur épingle du jeu avec 2,2 %
les Yvelines qui comptabilisaient fin
août
65780 personnes au chômage enfin apôle
emploi et aujourd'hui fin septembre nous
sommes à 64000 personnes c'est l'une
plus forte baisse enregistrée depuis
décembre 2000 malheureusement pourquoi
ces chiffres Haussmann ont-ils autant
baissé ce mois-ci et bien la version de
la courbe du chômage c'est une des
promesses de François Hollande et il a
mis tout les choses en ordre pour
pouvoir le faire comme le pacte de
responsabilité les employés les primes à
l'embauche tout fonctionnent à fond on
peut le dire c'est pour cette raison si
d'ailleurs que c'est la catégorie A et
les plus jeunes qui sont touchés par
cette forte baisse parce que c'était
l'une des promesses de François Hollande
permettent aux jeunes de retourner sur
le marché de l'emploi il y a aussi cette
fameuse ce plan formation qui doit
permettre à un million de personnes de
pouvoir les suivre et donc il y a
plusieurs organismes qui contribuent
comme pôle emploi ou encore face un club
d'entreprise 50 chinois qui aide au
retour à l'emploi je vous laisse écouter
Clarisse gors chargé de mission emploi à
face
alors apparemment
Osman on a un problème d'interview mais
on a bien compris en tout cas qu'on
avait un début d'inversion de la courbe
du chômage merci
Osman pour ses précisions